which one is real mature marry one are
you the real one which is the real
are you the ring hey hey how are you hmm
welcome to new day in San Francisco and
did some final editing some final cuts
to the montage it's gonna go up I hope
it does well what are we doing today
Marta mirror maze and aquarium you're
ready for this this is gonna break the
Internet nailed it what okay that should
be some points at least five let's see
if I know how to figure out this thing I
want coffee Jesus Christ shatter me huh
yes thanks
that is hope
thanks thanks thanks for putting dead
dammit
yeah oh god I can't get this stupid
window away
thanks for putting a bunch of [ __ ] my
computer appreciated thank you how is
how is this does this look cool that
looks pretty cool might say you like
this way if I check out with this will
you pay the hotel two days for legend of
the brofist two days you're over the
promise degree that she will pay for
that
that's out if I wear it like this do you
think I am a eunuch are I got free candy
because my hair was ugly and they were
like here you go
okay ugly hair man what kind of tourists
would go on a tour like that so done yes
okay see you guys
so apparently Alcatraz is the most
visited landmark in USA no wonder there
was no ticket what do we got
so right here we are here we need to go
here oh my god what let's have fun
something oh my god Oh bull
oh yeah mice is crazy by puffer fish
they're so ugly I don't get it
seventy experience 70 I'm not sure they
know how to diminish this work but
that's just me okay
mirror mace great okay I don't trust
this no what the hell
no oh God okay which money is real
you're not real you're really okay this
is cool
got it oh whoa no not yet
which one is real Matt yeah Mary what
are you the real one which in stereo
are you the yes now we went into circles
yes yes please don't be America
yeah you got a place the girlfriend you
decide upstairs a lot of carousels
so much yeah I'm gonna ride your baby
you kidding me
oh god it's starting yeah yeah
[Music]
I got I feel sick help me lift my leg
okay we're doing this one we have to
shoot but D dose yes
I beat you
legendary alright alright alright
might yeah epic hahahaha
it's lunch time let's go all right all
right this is the clam chowder
okay what's in the bread you know what
actually pretty good my Sarah ordered
the smallest sign whichever part of the
Hat grant I'm cool forever and ever
hey go oh my god
that guy's done with life isn't he [ __ ]
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
I found him oh I did it I found him
damn so pretty
very cool I remind me to never swim in
San Francisco look at that one oh my god
I want to want to swim me they all other
ones just chillin on top relateable
fishes oh my god what is that is he
wearing a sweater I like it
Hey
[Music]
one finger one finger I'll never wash
this hand alright alright alright
Watson what would you rate the aquarium
okay we're going back I'll give it a six
that looks awesome and that's the
mindset right there
[Music]
Hey
they're crazy hot
[Music]
come on give me a challenge
and need this
all right back home
[Music]
home sweet holy crap it's hide get the
AC yard are you ready for the cameras
this man why am i meeting a British man
in Los Angeles
it's strange it took eight so like 11
hours of flying to me in person yes
we're here we're gonna where we gonna do
we're gonna get drinks Felix nearly
killed me like it convinced me to
jaywalk he's alright cutting some Martin
huh
for those who don't know is a pro
parkour oh yes yeah so we're gonna - oh
no this is great
alright let's do some parkour yeah do it
Wow
[Music]
okay nice always the double splits look
at this yeah chips have left
that's like this is how I exit my New
York apartment look just like a little
spin that that works but I get picked up
by creepy guys let's get a wonderful
pirouette out the back of it with a burp
let's get going through the curtains
what if all right look at that guy
yes hey you want to go there Hey sorry
Oh to the ladies ladies ladies
yes it's gonna be amazing actually
because this club that would go in to
look cool I guess
you basically walk into it it's like a
it's like a vocal booth in a music
studio there's two really thick doors
and no I'm glad you explained it though
because people ena and I understand yeah
we're done high five come in think so
shame on our leader never mind Anka
maybe another yes BAE Martin is a cool
did I enjoy hanging out this is the end
of today's vlog I hope you enjoyed it if
you did some [ __ ] up I don't care
do what you want it's your alone life as
always we saw this and we were like we
have to stop this is gorgeous